and it's no secret how the valley has
evolved over the years and with an
influx of people moving here it makes
sense for more commercial development
the Southwest
of new retail shop are being built set
to open soon Madison Kimbrough joins us
live near Blue Diamond and rainbow
tonight with more on what's coming to
the neighborhood Madison
yeah Sasha not one but two new
developments are underway you can check
it out behind me as you can see
construction is currently in process
here at the Diamond Plaza which will
have five buildings from retail to
restaurants now I spoke to those in the
area who are pleased to see it
just really love how Vegas is expanding
you know for families and stuff that
it's not just about coming for parties
and stuff like that we have real people
living here it's awesome Julie Schuster
moved to the Southwest part of town 15
years ago and says it's impressive to
see all the growth it's a very very
beautiful thing we've actually been
living here since about 2008 and we've
seen like so many changes one of the
biggest as of recent this over 38 000
square feet of retail space the soon to
be shopping complex sits west of the
northwest corner of Rainbow and Blue
Diamond Gerald kluco who also lives in
the area welcomes the change as he says
the Southwest is a desirable place to be
there's a lot of people that that love
Vegas and they still like I say want
that little bit of a rural rural feel so
hence the reason why we're expanding out
in this area quite a bit Dapper
companies the developer of the property
says along with this massive project
they're almost finished with another
shopping center located just down the
way on Rainbow and many pleased with how
convenient it is it's nice to have you
know retail shops close restaurants and
so forth cuts down on your driving
across town so it's actually better for
the I think it's better for the
environment
some of the leases have yet to be
finalized for this particular retail
space and Dapper's still looking for
companies and restaurants to move in
reporting here live on Blue Diamond and
rainbow Madison Kimbrough 8 News Now